i'm gonna say tuesday around 10 15 p.m.
p.m. i won't say which tuesday oh no we
don't know I mean yeah it'sit's tough I
there are things I'm hopeful for I know
I was in LA recently and learned that I
guess everyone knows how the directors
are going to go right sit down and try
and hammer out a deal and I think
they're very confident that they will be
able to hammer out a deal that hopefully
will begin to foster a little bit less
animosity between our side and the other
side and begin to you know show the deal
can be made and I'm curious what that
deals going to be I know the directors
seek a different deal than than we are
seeking but I'm hopeful this doesn't go
as long as some people are saying it's
going to go and how long do you think
it's going to go they're saying you know
it could go into the spring to the
summer pilot season if they're saying by
the end of January if it's on over pilot
season to wash and those are all scary
things I always try not to look down the
road too far because then I can I gets a
little too scary yeah you know things
you know if it goes eight months or
something I'm saying the end of January
you're saying the energy just because I
really want to make a pilot and if it
ends buddy the January we could probably
still like a pilot let's hope
I'm gonna have about close to eight
thousand emails to respond to you know I
can't get into my office and my desk so
I'm sure they're really piling up this
is going to be a lot of penis extension
span that I'm gonna have to delete I'm
have to go in a day early and just
delete all of them or at least most of
them some upkeep it's gonna be hard to
get any work done their first day
because I think everyone's just gonna be
trying to catch up with everybody and
and I think every won't be happy to see
everybody even the people that hate each
other will be yes for a week or so I'm
gonna be happy just to get notes I
turned a movie and right before the
strike you know like everybody else did
the day before the strike i got this
movie turned in he spent four months
working on the movie you want to hear
what sure executives think and i have
not had any contact with those people
except is your wife giving any any node
tern she likes it yeah she thinks gonna
be funnier haha but it's solid affair
Amy could be funny yeah yeah that's what
she know um but I would really like some
feedback I get some free time yeah the
Golden Gloves got cancelled yeah and my
mom's mad at me you know right and it be
to see what happens at the Oscars and
something like that like that's a big
thing people are very disappointed about
the Golden Globes and if they don't have
the Oscars would be huge right right and
I'm not entirely sure all good PR
right right anything with Rob Schneider
yank it's get a good shot I don't know I
do like you know that that was gonna
kick out of it oh I thought she was
great also great I liked um no country
for old men love that I haven't seen
everything I've been watching a lot of
old movies with this strike yeah so I
think bad day at Black Rock I'll get
something this time around I don't know
what happened when it was released in
the 50s but it will be weird like it's
in that like with didn't they like just
with the Golden Globes like they like
when like like Robin Williams is
somewhere and they went in hand with
statue or something and they kind of do
unless think so they didn't have a show
right this is my hand about yeah yeah
I'm gonna go where ed Harris is supposed
to be and maybe they'll hand it to meet
my mistakes or something that's enough
hopefully i would bet it would be Obama
vs Huckabee that would be mine that
would be if I was in Vegas that would be
who i would bet on those two guys I
think it's gonna be Hillary versus
McCain oh yeah I didn't even mention
McCain I forget this also there's a lot
of great personalities this one and it's
also it's so much more up in the air for
both sides than it normally is you know
you don't have an incumbent running you
don't have a VP you running and it's
changing from day to day you know every
week it's gonna be different and if
somebody makes a huge gaffe maybe comes
on something like this they could blow
it um I mean I think somebody makes a
big mistake or some plunder and that
could be bad so I'm glad that I've got
10 hours a day to sit and watch c-span
ya know about you yeah I'm think I'm
gonna see ya
you